des diringer zinedine zidane et eric
tabarly jacques anquetil
ils font partie des grands athlètes
décoré de la légion d'honneur
nous vous faisons chevalier de la légion
d'honneur ça paraît naturel aujourd'hui
le décor et des sportifs mais ce n'est
que dans les années 60 ils se sont
défaits de leur image de simples
maniaque de la performance les champions
à quelques sports qu'ils se consacrent
ont désormais partie des élites d'une
nation au même type
et pourquoi pas que les intellectuels de
toutes catégories
alors qu'avant la légion été remises à
des sportifs en fin de carrière
depuis les années 60 la jeunesse est à
l'honneur immédiatement après des
exploitants qui nous attendait pas je
pensais que ce serait beaucoup plus tard
vraiment c'était très une attente en
honneur quoique la légion d'honneur de
toute façon de me transformer absolument
pas si je s'il fallait attendre la
légion d'honneur pour être transformée
j'estime qu'on juge les gens plus pour
ce qu'ils représentent que parce qu'ils
ont l'âge légion d'honneur la question
d'être fait chevalier se posent parfois
par des sportifs même comme raymond
poulidor en 1962 à titre militaire quand
elle a été créée par napoléon mais aussi
à titre civil il
légion récompense les actions
remarquables est reconnu comme modèle
pour la société logique donc que les
sportifs reçoivent la légion ceux qui
contribuent au rayonnement de la france
à l'international
et bien maintenant c'est ouvert à tous
les talents de chez tatouille talon qui
se sont manifestés au service de la
communauté nationale
des centaines de sportifs ont été sacré
chevalier officier commandeur de la
légion d'honneur
mais attention la performance seul ne
suffit pas de grands athlètes n'ont pas
pu être distinguée comme le handballeur
nicolas karabatic ou le perchiste renaud
lavillénie la faute à des condamnations
judiciaires
[Musique]
mon père nos erreurs